welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Marvel's secret Invasion makes
the MCU in 2023 the year of Fury
considering we are going to see this guy
again in the Marvels this November but
our man Fury has spent many years on
this Earth and he has one of the most
interesting biographies of any MCU
character and it's filled with secrets
that are even now as of secret Invasion
Episode 2 finally coming to life so in
this hero rewind let's shine a light on
this one-eyed super spy to see how he's
been saving the world from the Shadows
since the beginning and a reminder to
subscribe to all three of the channels
on the new rockstars Network including
our new channel the break room which is
the new home of our secret Invasion
after shows inside Marvel okay Samuel L
Jackson is the longest running actor in
the MCU playing Nick Fury for over 15
years in 11 movies 4 episodes of the
what if Disney plus animated series and
two episodes of Agents of Shield and ABC
which we will include for when Kevin
feige finally brings in agent coulson's
life model decoy and Chloe Bennett Quake
to save this franchise there's still
time and all that before what I consider
now to be finally his story role in
secret Invasion when we first meet Fury
in 2008's Iron Man but in 2019's Captain
Marvel set 1995 filled in more of his
history we see his ID listing his birth
date as July 4th 1950. July 4th is also
Steve Rogers birthday He's listed as
Shield level 3 back then later in his
career Hill rise to the clearance level
10. his low clearance level here
probably explains why up until this
point he was unaware of the existence of
alien life forms and that there were
likely other individuals and shields who
did have that knowledge but the events
of the Captain Marvel film will show his
first witnessing of a scroll when one
takes the form of his partner Agent
Coulson but in this movie when he's
talking with Carol Danvers we learn more
of his backstory and his upbringing
where were you born Huntsville Alabama
but technically I don't remember that
part first job Soldier straight out of
high school left the rights of full bird
colonel then spy where it's a cold war
we were everywhere Belfast Bucharest
Belgrade Budapest I like the bees I can
make them right ah another one of those
bees is Bogota when he became Deputy
Chief of a shield station under the
command of Alexander Pierce the
Secretary of State in Captain America
Winter Soldier Pierce's daughter was
taken hostage by a rebel group in Bogota
and fury came up with a plan to rescue
them and his success here put him on a
path to becoming director of Shield
interesting to note now Bogota does show
up
show up terrorist strikes in secret
Invasion Episode 1 maybe a sign of Fury
taking his eye off the ball now in the
Captain Marvel film set in 1995 as Fury
meets Carol Danvers upon a return to
Earth and helping uncover her Cree
brainwashing win back in 1989 as an air
force test pilot she got implicated in
the creek killing of the scientist Wendy
Lawson for helping the squirrels build a
tesseract powered Lightspeed engine to
find them a new home World throughout
this movie Fury has a cut over his eye a
bit of a fake out that we thought would
lead to his famous injury that requires
his eye patch but nope twins but to
scratch by gustaflirkin that was a close
call huh goofy
you okay yeah it's just a scratch this
movie also reveals Fury's Infamous
toast-cutting pet peeve name a details
so bizarre a squirrel could never
fabricate it a toast is cut diagonally I
can't eat it and no fury does not cut
his toes diagonally in Age of Ultron
trust me on this but Fury does make a
big deal about how everyone just calls
him Fury not Nicholas not Joseph not
Nick just Fury mom call you Fury what do
you call her Fury what about your kids
if I have them they'll call me fury it
explains how he knows later that his
boss is actually Talos excellent work
Nicholas
but we have definitely heard other MC
characters call him other things over
the years specifically Maria Hill and
the Avengers Infinity War post credit
scene in Captain Marvel Fury helps this
girl refugees escape the Creed he sets
up a pager Communicator with Carol
Danvers befriends Halos Soren and the
young Gaia in Louisiana in honor of
Carol's call sign of Avenger he renames
his new hero initiative The Avengers
Initiative and he feeds Goose to
Tesseract and thank you to better help
for sponsoring this video here at new
rockstars we like to figure out what
makes movies work go frame by frame to
figure out what's really going on but
when we need Insight on what's really
going on with ourselves we use better
help betterhelp is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
you your therapist isn't the right fit
for any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge better
help gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com new rockstars
for 10 off your first month of therapy
now secret information episode 2
establishes that shortly after this in
1997 in Brixton of the UK Fury promises
a group of Scrolls that if they stay
hidden on Earth wearing human identities
he would work to find them a new home
world this group included a young
graphic and this girl who would become
his wife Priscilla Fury Fury actually
referenced this wife back in Winter
Soldier but we didn't know then how
serious he was being my wife kicked me
out
didn't know you were married
a lot of things you don't know about me
okay so jumping ahead and Fury's life to
the late OTS Fury recruited Tony Stark
in the Iron Man post credit scene and
repeated his efforts in Iron Man 2 and
we learned from the end of this film
that on Fury's radar is both wakanda and
talocon pings on Shield's world map in
the background of that final scene now
the events of Iron Man 2 are all part of
what was later referred to as Fury's big
week which included the events of Iron
Man 2 Thor the Incredible Hulk and the
ending of Captain America the First
Avenger this leads us to Loki's invasion
in the 2012 Avengers movie when Fury
headed up Project Pegasus to research a
tesseract sir please put down the spear
we have no quarrel with your people an
ant has no quarrel with a boot Fury
calls us back later and
boot now in this movie Fury talks to the
world Security Council a board of
shadowy figures some of whom later turn
out to be Hydra like Gideon Malik it was
designed for exactly these two isn't
ready our enemy is we need a response
team The Avengers Initiative was shut
down now phase two obviously a joke to
Marvel phase two but there's also a
Shield's plan to roll out the Tesseract
powered weapons and we learned that Nick
Fury before 2008 had been trying to
recruit other Avengers over the years
but the world Security Council shut it
down which is important to know there
might have been other Avengers that we
have not met yet and he has one detail
I'm obligated to mention from the 2012
Avengers film wind Fury briefs Steve
Rogers the finally handsome mentioned
Thanos the infinity gems and Mephisto
Mephisto so technically Fury knew about
memphisto back in 2012 Fury exploits the
death of Phil Coulson to motivate The
Avengers to work together down to
snaring some of coulson's Captain
America trading cards in his own blood
and while the Avengers fight Loki's
forces Fury fights the world security
council's called to Nuke the city I
recognize the council has made a
decision but given that it's a stupid
ass decision I have elected to ignore it
now this brings us to Agents of Shield
when Fury uses Creed blood and project
Tahiti the project designed to resurrect
a fallen Avenger to resurrect Coulson
Fury shows up in the second episode of
the series just after colson's recruits
come together as a team really
really Colson
six days it only took you six days to
take a completely renovated piece of
state-of-the-art machinery and turn it
into scrap now the intention was for
Agents of Shield to be MCU Cannon but
over the years Marvel Studios ignored
the events of the series but again I
repeat it is not too late to clarify
Agents of Shield as proper Cannon and
Captain America the Winter Soldier fury
expounds on his lack of trust when he
tells cap a story about his grandfather
who worked as an elevator operator who
is apparently based on Jackson's actual
grandfather you ever get mugged
hmm
every week some punk would say what's in
the bag
what would he do
he chilling
bunch of couple ones and a loaded 22
magnum Granddad love people
but he didn't trust them very much
Perry tells another anecdote in secret
information episode two talking about
how he and his mom would have to take
train rides from Alabama to Detroit and
have to ride in a segregated train car
and how they pass the time by playing
games like tell me something I don't
know which is how he got so good at
lying but more importantly knowing when
other people were lying and when her
Soldier Fury survives multiple attempts
on his life and fakes his death to
expose hydra's corruption shield and
their plot to use project insight
helicarriers to assassinate their
enemies the movie ends with Fury going
off the grid so you've experienced this
sort of thing before
you get used to it now that quote on its
gravestone is Ezekiel 25 17 a nice
little nod to Samuel L Jackson's famous
speech from Pulp Fiction we actually
learned that in secret Invasion Fury has
fake Graves everywhere Fury should have
again an Agents of Shield just after the
events of Winter Soldier chronologically
coming out of Heidi an attempt to nail
another Hydra operative so
you don't have to call me sir Coulson
look at me I'm just like I live under a
bridge Fury shuts up again in Age of
Ultron on Clinton Barton's Farm back to
spotting that eye patch artificial
intelligence
you never even hesitated Fury has likely
been wary of AI ever since seeing the
cree and Captain Marvel who were
governed by a corrupt Supreme
intelligence and yeah he saw how
dangerous Zola's AI was in Project
Insight once again Fury sets The
Avengers on the right path like the good
dad that he is and gives him the Boost
they need to get back in the fight back
in the day I had eyes everywhere ears
everywhere else you kids had all the
tick you could dream of
here we all are back on Earth
with nothing but our wit and our will to
save the world and in the final battle
he saves all the zakubians on a hill
carrier with some old Shield contacts
now we do not see Nick Fury again until
and summons Captain Marvel
after the Avengers reverse the step in
endgame Fury shows up at Tony Stark's
funeral and then in Spider-Man far from
home the real knit Fury was off world
having assigned Talos to get Peter
Parker Tony Stark's eated glasses while
Fury was on the Scrolls space station
that we later Learned was saber now far
from home did some serious damage to the
city of London which Sonya Falls were
the references in secret Invasion
Episode 1 showing that these two spies
also have a history together and now in
Phase five of the MCU we're seeing a lot
more of saber which is part of Nick
Fury's interplanetary defense system
signed off by the White House Fury
apparently trying to continue Tony
Stark's longtime mission to build a suit
of armor around the world and as we will
see in the Marvel's trailer he has
Allied himself with Monaco Rambo to pick
back up with swords astronaut programs
so some fresh takeaways about Nick Fury
as we celebrate this year of Fury one
he's learned not to trust people after
growing up in Alabama in the 50s too he
but in the Cold War and has been has
been since cities all over the world
three in 1997 he promises throw new home
planet but never followed through and
now spends most of his time on saber
four previously works with other
Avengers we haven't met yet like maybe
Wolverine 5 has a wife who's a scroll
six kids weapons and supplies and
several fake Graves seven knows how to
resurrect people via Tahiti which could
come in handy and eight knows about
Mephisto you can support this growing
Network by grabbing something from our
store nerd riot.shop subscribe to new
rockstars along with the Deep dive and
the break room on YouTube and all social
platforms you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos thanks for watching
bye
[Music]